[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce mercredi 16 juin premier
match des bleus réussit aussi bien pour
l'équipe de france que pour l'engouement
des supporters ils débutaient leur euro
2020 par un match contre l'allemagne qui
l'ont remporté les supporters yvelinois
étaient au rendez vous pour les soutenir
même avec les mesures sanitaires
nous irons à saint germain en laye après
presque deux années de restauration le
bosquet de la reine du château de
versailles vient de rouvrir ses portes
une réouverture qui coïncide aussi avec
le retour des touristes dans la ville
nous inviter à ce sujet sophie hébert
directrice générale de l'office de
tourisme et philippe pas un président de
l'umih 78 et enfin d'édition quatre
petites chouettes viennent de s'envoler
vers l'allemagne
né à l'espace rambouillet ce transfert
s'inscrit dans le cadre du programme de
réhabilitation de la chouette de l'oural
en bavière
juste avant cela le premier ministre
jean castex s'est exprimé ce mercredi 16
juin sur la crise sanitaire
il a annoncé la levée des restrictions
plus tôt que prévu le couvre-feu à 23h
et donc levé à compter de ce dimanche 6h
du matin également le port du masque en
extérieur n'est plus obligatoire dès
demain jeudi 17 juin sauf dans certains
cas comme sur les marchés par exemple
il reste néanmoins obligatoire à
l'intérieur autre actualité suite à une
baisse de la demande
trois centres de vaccination fermeront
bientôt leurs portes dans les yvelines
chatou à partir du 13 juillet
rambouillet à partir du 17 juillet et
bonnières sur seine à partir du 30
juillet les personnes ayant des rendez
vous après ces dates devront prendre
rendez vous dans un autre centre de
vaccination à proximité ou bien à celui
qui vient d'ouvrir mardi dernier velizy
[Musique]
ce mardi soir le match de l'équipe de
france face à l'allemagne a été suivie
par plus de 15 millions de
téléspectateurs sur les écrans français
dans les yvelines les bars et
restaurants ont fait le plein malgré le
contexte sanitaire et le couvre-feu
nous nous sommes rendus du côté de saint
germain en laye pour suivre la rencontre
reportage de michael almy d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude ce mardi 15
juin séjour de match à saint germes en
les les bars et restaurants sont bien
remplies pour voir l'entrée en lice de
la france face à l'allemagne à l'euro
après la traditionnelle marseillaise
l'ambiance monte d'un cran quand la
france marque le premier but de la
partie à la 20e minute suite à une
erreur du défenseur allemand mats
hummels le score ne changera plus
jusqu'à la pause au plus grand plaisir
des supporters les blancs bien joué il a
été brûlé vif quand même à but contre
leur camp mais plutôt bien la france
avant je pense que la deuxième mi temps
ça ira beaucoup mieux pour nous et puis
les ça va démarrer beaucoup mieux 3 0
pour la france sic moi je dis 3 0 tous
et à distance par ses supporters divino
installée à 700 kilomètres du stade de
munich les bleus pense doubler la mise
en seconde période mais kylie ann m bape
et puis karim benzema voit leur but
refusé pour hors jeu
le coup de sifflet final libère
finalement les fans victoire 1-0 en a eu
un gros match équipe de france et aussi
l'allemagne très gros match mais vive la
france continue comme ça on va on va y
aller en droit dedans prochain match
pour les bleus ce samedi 19 juin contre
la hongrie une nouvelle occasion pour
ses fans libinois de s'enflammer
lol
direction versailles à présent après
presque deux ans de fermeture pour
travaux ce lundi 14 juin marquer la
réouverture du bosquet de la reine au
château de versailles datant du xviiie
siècle lieu à retrouverez son d'esprit
de l'époque grâce à la plantation de
nouveaux arbustes arbres et rose une
réouverture qui intervient presque à la
même période que celle de l'intérieur du
château de versailles marquant la
renaissance de ce lieu historique et le
tourisme qui repart notre reportage avec
astrid bergère après près de deux ans de
restauration le bosquet de la reine du
château de versailles a rouvert ses
portes lundi 14 juin le lieu c'était
dénaturé au cours des 19 et 20ème
siècles similar buts et 500 arbres ont
donc été replantés au total une
soixantaine d'essence et de variétés
forme le bosquet d'autres travaillent
pendant le premier hiver a surtout
consisté à rétablir la salle centrale
est replanté des tulipiers et puis
depuis l'automne dernier et jusqu'à
quelques il ya quelques jours
là on s'est attaché à restituer les
salles de verdure périphériques toutes
les petites allées qui mène d'une salle
à l'autre et finalement voilà à trouver
a retrouvé la place de chaque végétal
xviiie siècle certaines variétés de
roses ayant disparu elles ont été
remplacées par des similaire est
toujours dans la palette de
marie-antoinette blanches roses ou
abricoté et la fin de la restauration
arrive au moment de la réouverture du
château de versailles
l'occasion de retrouver les visiteurs
ceyrac public nous a beaucoup manqué
donc même si ça a été l'opportunité de
mener bon train
voilà certains travaux certains
chantiers et on en a profité autant
qu'on le pouvait c'est vrai que tout ce
qu'on fait ici on le fait d'abord pour
le partager
notre principale vocation à versailles
c'est de transmettre un patrimoine c'est
de valoriser de le faire connaître
donc évidemment une grande partie de
notre travail ne trouve son sens qu'avec
le public
ce lieu est idéal pour se reposer
prendre le temps et être calme marie
antoinette avait choisi d'avoir un
jardin réservé justement pour être aussi
à l'abri de tout ce que lui avait
imposée le protocole donc je crois que
nos visiteurs pour avoir aussi la chance
d'avoir un jardin réservé au calme où
ils pourront être dans la contemplation
au total la restauration a coûté près de
2 millions d'euros
bientôt une campagne de mécénat sera
lancée pour pouvoir installer d'autres
bandes dans les salles de verdure et
pour continuer à parler du tourisme qui
repart à versailles
nous accueillons en visioconférence avec
nous le secrétaire général et président
de l'union des métiers de l'industrie
hôtelière des yvelines l'umih 60 18
philippins bonsoir également présente
avec nous pour parler du tourisme la
directrice générale de l'office de
tourisme de versailles
sophie hébert bonsoir commença alors
depuis l'allègement des restrictions
sanitaires liés aux covit 19 la vie
reprend peu à peu son cours
cela devrait même être d'autant plus le
cas à partir de ce dimanche 20 juin avec
la fin du couvre-feu
sophie hébert quel état du tourisme en
ce moment dans la commune de versailles
est ce que les touristes font leur grand
retour alors effectivement avec la
réouverture des principaux sites
touristiques sur versailles l'activité
touristique reprend petit à petit c'est
néanmoins un retour progressif des
touristes que nous enregistrons puisque
nous sommes et nous restons très très
loin des flux de fréquentation
touristique habituel et ça c'est lié
principalement à la typologie de
clientèle puisque à peu près 80% de la
clientèle est étrangère à versailles et
avec les frontières qui restent fermées
et les voyages internationaux qui reste
très très compliqué septe clientèle
aujourd'hui nous manque donc très
concrètement ce sont essentiellement des
français et surtout des franciliens que
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir à
versailles actuellement
et c'est vrai que c'est une clientèle
qui redécouvre en fait une ville qu'il
connaît essentiellement pour son château
et du coup ils en profitent pour visiter
d'autres sites
alors philippin on le sait votre
profession votre corps de métiers
l'industrie hôtelière a été très impacté
par la crise sanitaire
elle est très lié également au tourisme
principalement à versailles cette
reprise du tourisme peu à peu et ce
qu'elle se fait ressentir dans votre
profession
oui absolument ce que disait sophie sait
on voit réapparaître donc clientèle de
proximité sont pas très loin de la
région parisienne commence à revenir s
est ressaisi en redemande
le week-end surtout eux ils appelent à
celle ci dans la courette revient telle
affaire aux viandes semaine sur les
hôtels
il ya deux catégories standard est
chargé par exemple se fier ibère on
imagine que la reverso château de
versailles aussi fait revenir les
touristes vous l'avait déjà évoqué est
ce que c'est vraiment important cette
réouverture aussi du château même si les
jardins étaient ouverts quand même
depuis quelques temps ah oui bien sûr
c'est très important et c'est surtout
l'opportunité de visiter château de
versailles dans des conditions bien plus
agréable que lorsque nous sommes au plus
fort de nos fréquentation touristique
le château a mis en place un système de
billetterie horodatées ce qui permet au
visiteur également d'organiser le mieux
son séjour sur versailles et de déliés
vraiment une plage de visite au château
est également de s'organiser pour
visiter un autre chose d'alcool potager
du roi par exemple ou d'autres d'autres
sites intéressants sur versailles mais
c'est vrai que le château bar est connu
et est un est un monument majeur est
très intéressant qui donne à versailles
bien entendu une visibilité très très
forte
j'imagine que vous avez le même point de
vue philippe insu pour vous votre votre
corps de profession oui alors de ville
début mai donc voilà la reprise qui des
jours heureux qui sont là enfin depuis
début mai sa commence a frémi et puis en
voyant sa montée en puissance
pour cet été donc c'est plus incertain
mais je pense que les clientèles aux
derniers mois chimiste déjà carnet de
commandes un peu par huit par le taux
d'occupation en ce moment entre 40 et 60
c'est pas ou pas du tout ce qu'il ya
vraiment des gens nés en tout 40 50%
mais c'est pas encore c'est pas encore
ça donc on espère le coup de coeur cet
été des français qui patrouillaient la
versa y est et en plus en ce moment mois
de juin comme il ya le mois molière
versailles c'est une bonne chose pour
les gens qui sont de proximité des
courses estivales
peut-être un peu réduit cette année mais
avec une grande qualité comme d'habitude
et justement en continu avec vous
philippin qu'est la tendance pour cet
été au niveau de l'hôtellerie la
restauration bas comme je dis alors
restauration c'est bien certain de
fonctionner avec le tourisme étranger
dont faisaient souffrir ils ne sont pas
présents a forcément on court on espère
que cet été ici reviendrons c'est la
tante aussi des professionnels
en revanche on les restaurateurs on est
la seule survivante est les hawks imiter
les jauges sont pas encore à 100% ou
encore on espère que les amendes les
enfants rendez-vous milliards les
terrasses sont déjà prises et depuis le
début d'un regard sur les terrasses au
quasiment topless versailles à paris
et j'imagine comme je le disais tout à
l'heure la fin du couvre-feu va aussi
peut-être permettre d'accentuer le lay
les choses au niveau touristique et
restauration hôtellerie pour vous sophie
hébert j'imagine que vous avez aussi dû
vous réinventer à l'office de tourisme
est-ce que vous avez mis des choses en
place particulière pour cet été
alors effectivement il a fallu qu'on se
réinvente complètement
comme vous pouvez l'imaginer les
attentes d'une clientèle locale ou
françaises sont complètement différent
d'une attente des attentes d'une
clientèle internationale
donc on a réfléchi à mettre en place une
offre à destination des familles donc
susceptible de satisfaire aussi bien les
parents que les enfants également des
offres plus diversifiée plus variés pour
pouvoir familiariser un petit peu nos
visiteurs aux différents attraits de la
ville de versailles
on s'inscrit notamment dans un programme
qui s'appelle le pass malin desjardins
qui a été mis en place en collaboration
avec le département des yvelines sur
versailles pour pouvoir faire découvrir
en extérieur les jardins les coins de
verdure que peut proposer la ville de
versailles les visiteurs bénéficieront
bien entendu d'une réduction de 15 % sur
les tarifs de ces sites là et on va
retrouver aussi bien la ferme nature et
découvertes donc là qui s'adresse
typiquement à une clientèle familiale
que le potager du roi le domaine de
madame elisabeth où l'une des visites
aux alentours du grand trianon où du
domaine de marie-antoinette donc des
choses que le public connaît peut-être
un petit peu moins mais qui répond
vraiment à une attente et un
questionnement d'un public français
tout est fait donc on l'entend de vous
deux merci philippins merci sophie
hébert tout est fait pour que le
tourisme repartent merci d'avoir été
avec mon feu
[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité une
application pour guider les personnes en
situation de déficience visuelle à la
gare de versailles chantiers est en
phase de test appelé navy lance le
dispositif mis en place par versailles
grand parc et la société keolis a déjà
ses premiers utilisateurs
reportage de célia 400 go et bixente
mais rien senti steban si vous croisez
ceux petits carrés colorés aux alentours
de la gare de versailles chantiers
il s'agit d'un qr codes de
l'expérimentation la vilaine ce
dispositif vise à aider les personnes
atteintes de déficience visuelle
kerbellec malvoyantes est l'application
14 marche puis palier +13 marche tout en
haut
scannez le code avant pied fait
technologie peut bien aidé à la
personnes malvoyantes ou non voyantes
dans le dans le sens que on conseille
vers où aller
et d'avoir les enseignements si on est
bien sur le chemin qu'on veut parcourir
le parcours a été étudié pour être le
plus instinctif possible des arrêts de
bus en dehors de la gare jusqu'au quai
intersection une fois à l'intersection
portique de validation des formations
sncf à 10h et l'information aux
voyageurs aujourd'hui pour s'assurer que
les usagers profitent pleinement de
cette qualité de transport c'est devenu
quelque chose d'essentiel
et parmi l'information voyageur il ya le
sujet de l'inclusivité qui est parfois
difficile à dresser et ki ena vilain
cela pour le coup nous apporte une
solution qui me semblait très
intéressante à tester développé par
versailles grand parc et la société
keolis le dispositif pourrait être
élargie à d'autres usages en cas de
réussite de la phase de test mi juillet
le jdd clients occasionnels des
touristes qui pourrait tout à fait
utiliser cette solution si tant est
qu'elle soit adaptée à ses besoins
quant aux testeurs il a déjà soumis
quelques axes d'amélioration il
souhaiterait une indication du numéro du
bus qui arrive est un système
miniaturisés pour moi attiré l'oeil des
autres passants un nouveau propriétaire
pour l'espace 50 ans le groupe allianz
commerce vient d'acquérir à 100% le
centre commercial de montigny le
bretonneux la gestion a été confiée à
altarea commerce avec des ambitions
renforcer l'attractivité de l'espace
saint quentin notre reportage avec
nicolas landry le centre commercial
espace saint quentin un nouveau
gestionnaire
altarea commerce a été choisi par le
groupe allianz pour s'occuper de ce site
une décision suite au rachat de la
participation d' hammerson par le groupe
allemand de l'assurance et altaréa
commerce a déjà une vision pour l'espace
commercial de montigny le bretonneux
alors c'est un actif très intéressant
puisqu'il a effectivement beaucoup de
fondamentaux
très intéressant il a un bassin d'emploi
très important 145 mille emplois sur la
zone sur seize mille entreprises des
universités écoles un centre de loisirs
et des actifs de loisirs très importante
avec un cinéma avec effectivement un
théâtre également dans la bande dans la
zone l'espace saint quentin c 130
boutiques sur soixante mille mètres
carrés avec près de 12 millions de
visiteurs par an une base sur laquelle
altarea commerce va s'appuyer pour
compléter l'offre de restauration de
loisirs et de services à la personne
proposés sur la zone mais pas seulement
on a également eu un enjeu de
diversification de l'offre sur des
activités qui manque un peu au niveau du
site
je pense notamment à la décoration à
l'équipement de la maison à
l'ameublement objectif renforcer
l'attractivité de ce centre commercial
qui date de 1987 avec la possibilité de
voir arriver de nouvelles enseignes
beaucoup de discussions vous l'imaginez
sont encore en cours sur sur différents
sujets de commercialisation il ya des
travaux qui sont engagés et que nous
reprenons à la suite de l'ancien
gestionnaire
donc on s'appelle effectivement déjà à
cette reprise qui est très importante
pour nous est fondamental pour pour la
suite pour le groupe altarea commerce
l'espace saint quentin vient compléter
un portefeuille d'actifs il gère
actuellement 2000 beau sur 40 centres
commerciaux en france
elsa triolet résistante première femme
ayant reçu le prix goncourt traductrice
de tchekhov ou encore céline elle
disparaissait le 16 juin 1970 pour
l'occasion la maison elsa triolet aragon
avec la poste a édité un timbre à son
effigie
il n'a pu être présente et que cette
année pour le 51e anniversaire en raison
de la crise sanitaire à l'année dernière
cela a eu lieu à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines samedi 12 juin
à l'ancien domicile de l'artiste à
l'occasion d'une journée d'hommage
la demande est venue de la maison elsa
triolet on a sollicité la poste en
prévision d'un en amont du 50e
anniversaire de sa mort mais vous savez
la conception d'un timbre c'est c'est
long et on a eu le plaisir de le faire
avec la poste en lien étroit et la poste
a aussitôt accepté de propositions
c'était la moindre des choses je crois
pour pour célébrer
la première femme prix goncourt une
romancière de grande importance une
traductrice majeur au total 480 15000
exemplaires seront tirés ils sont
disponibles dans 2000 bureaux de poste
et ce pendant une année et pour refermer
ce journal quatre jeunes chouettes de
l'espace rambouillet viennent de
s'envoler vers l'allemagne
né le 15 mai dernier d'un couple de
chouettes appartenant à la société les
ailes de l'urga et au parc animalier un
transfert dans le cadre du programme de
réhabilitation de la chouette de l'oural
en bavière
le reportage de bérangère bourgoin
quatre choix de l'oral de l'espace
rambouillet ont pris la route lundi 14
juin
direction l'allemagne où elles vont
progressivement retrouver leur liberté
dans le cadre d'un programme de
renforcement de population dans le
milieu naturel en direction de
l'allemagne de la bavière
on va se replacer dans une volière en
plein de forêt aménagée spécialement
pour ces jeunes chouettes de l'oural et
elles vont y passer deux à trois
semaines
d'autant qu'à 5,5 l'imap et ensuite une
grande porte soit ouverte ou cette
volière
ils pourront sortir tous les jours
rentrée jusqu'avant donner ou à vont
prendre leur indépendance
c'est une première pour l'espace
rambouillet qui n'avaient pas encore pu
participer à ce programme puisque seuls
les jeunes individus peuvent être
réintégrés le programme a été mis en
place depuis trois ans par les allemands
il ya différents parcs zoologiques en
france et en europe qui alimente ce
programme avec des jeunes nés en
captivité et nous c'est la première
année on a quatre bébés qui vont pouvoir
partir l'an dernier l'an dernier il ya
deux ans donc on n'a pas eu de jeunes
donc on pouvait pas participer à cette
année on a eu beaucoup de chance
le soignant est confiant pour cette
réintroduction les chouettes n'ont pas
été élevés par la main humaine mais par
leurs parents elle le rechercherons pas
l'homme quand elles retrouveront leur
liberté
sa volée elles savent le faire
il a aucun souci après on va apprendre
la prédation donc quand il ajoutant
qu'elles vont rester dans cette volière
les allemands qui se clippe et c'est
toujours mettre des souris vivantes et
des petits campagnols vivant mais quatre
chouettes de l'espace rambouillet seront
relâchés début juillet elles
continueront à être nourris dans leur
volière le temps qu'elles prennent leur
indépendance
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information revient
demain à 18h en direct dans le 7-8
journal présenté par grégory canale et
d'ici là je vous souhaite une très belle
soirée
[Musique]